die vertreter der fdp spitze ein kubala
ein fdp-sprecher begrüße river kirchen
spitzenkandidat der fdp in sachsen
anhalt und martin reichert den
landessprecher der design sonst herzlich
willkommen aber zuständig kubala fängt
an bitteschön fällt drauf auch von
meiner seite herzlich willkommen heute
zur bundespressekonferenz
als nachbereitung zur landtagswahl in
sachsen anhalt zuerst
möchte ich mich bei den vielen
wahlkämpfern in sachsen-anhalt bedanken
für dieses doch respektabel ergebnis 20
über 20 prozent wird man sicherlich
gerne gewünscht ist 12 prozent mehr
seien hätten können möchte mich bei
unserem spitzenkandidaten sachsen-anhalt
oliver kirchner für diesen doch sehr
anstrengen und auch aufopferungsvollen
wahlkampf bedanken bedanken und diesen
durch schwierigen bedingungen die wir
alle als parteien halten was die
mobilisierung angehen denke ich hatten
wir alle unsere probleme also von daher
denke ich haben wir trotz all dem ein
sehr respektables ergebnis
erzielt das für mich auch glücklich
macht wir sind über 20 prozent haben
unser ergebnis wie gesagt gefestigt
haben eine steuerstruktur mittlerweile
sind auch in sachsen anhalt weiter
volkspartei das haben wir gezeigt und
konnten uns auch damit konsolidieren
als erfolg möglich auch hier klarstellen
dass vier grad in der wähler kurorte
unter der 33-jährigen zugelegt haben
beziehungsweise sogar stärkste partei
geworden sind da so gerade die jungen
wähler haben wir mobilisieren können die
afg zu wählen auch das denke ich ist ein
starkes zeichen dass wir mit unserer
politik was die themen soziale themen ja
in diesem landtagswahlkampf einigen
innere sicherheit aber auch die
wirtschaftlichen themen die dort
sicherlich mit von bedeutung waren in
diesem sinne das jetzt erst mal von
meiner seite ich danke nochmal wie
gesagt den vielen wahlkämpfen in sachsen
anhalt auch den vielen mitstreitern für
die es ist doch gut der ergebnis
ja vielen dank auch von mir herzlichen
gruß in die runde die kernaussage ist es
gibt zwei volksparteien in sachsen
anhalt und es gibt vier die keine mehr
sind und
zum ergebnis muss ich sagen ich bin da
sehr zufrieden mit weil ich natürlich
auch feststellen musste dass ein jahr
lang das arbeit die nicht so cool
politiker domning medien wie wir es uns
gewünscht hätten dazu geführt haben dass
es für uns schwierig war aber ich glaube
wir haben ein stammwählerpotenzial von
über 20 prozent es waren es knapp 21 ich
hätte mir 23 mehr gewünscht das wäre
auch so passiert nun ist es aber so dass
natürlich diese umfragewerte die wir
vorher hatten genau dafür gesorgt haben
dass es einen kopf an kopf rennen der
afg und der cdu geben sollte ich bin ein
bisschen vorsichtiger geblieben und habe
immer gesagt zwischen 23 und 26 prozent
wäre schön und habe nie davon gesprochen
30 prozent oder mehr zu erreichen weil
ich wusste dass das schwierig wird und
die ergebnisse und die umfragen zeigen
uns jetzt dass selbst die linke in
größenordnung die cdu gewählt hat um uns
zu verhindern und wenn die linke die
grünen die fdp und die spd in großen
magen diese cdu wählen um die afg als
stärkste kraft zu verhindern dann kann
man diese landtagswahl nicht gewinnen
trotzdem bin ich froh darüber dass wir
dieses wählerpotenzial haben und muss
feststellen dass das land wieder
konservativ gewählt hat wir werden sehen
wie der kollege haselhoff jetzt damit
umgeht und was er für eine koalition aus
rufen wird
wir haben sehr gute oppositionsarbeit
geleistet das werden wir auch weiterhin
so tun wir haben uns stabilisiert wir
sind verlässliche worden und wenn wir
jetzt noch fünf jahre machen dann glaube
ich schon dass wir auch in
regierungsverantwortung treten können
weil wir eben jetzt mit einem stamm in
diesem landtag sitzen und mit neuen
kollegen geht es auch weiterhelfen
werden dass sich frohen mutes gerade was
der kollege kubala sache in die zukunft
schauen weil wir haben nicht nur bis 30
dieser ball gewonnen wir haben die wahl
gewonnen bei den 18 bis 40 jährigen und
das ist die gute zukunft dieses landes
wenn wir es schaffen werden in zukunft
das zu analysieren was uns jetzt
passiert es dann kann ich mir sehr gut
vorstellen dass wir auch bei den
rentnern euro wieder zulegen weil das
coen thema ist den europäern auch zu
ende und ich glaube da können wir uns
auch wie in geschichten zurückholen um
das ergebnis noch deutlich auszubauen
das wär's gewesen
vielen dank dafür in nacka kirchner herr
reichert
schönen guten tag auch erst mal die
runde also mich hat an diesem
wahlergebnis letztlich besonders erfreut
dass wir ja auch mit einem starken und
der bürgerlichen programm hier diesen
erfolg erringen konnten wir haben uns
für die bürgerrechte eingesetzt in der
korona frage das war sehr wichtig an
zweiter stelle haben wir einen ganz
klaren fokus auf die familienpolitik
gelegt auf die traditionelle familie auf
die förderung von kindern und familien
das ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt den wir
denke ich gespielt haben was ist
bürgerlicher als bürgerrechte und
familien das muss man ja mal ganz
deutlich sagen und unser weiterer
kernpunkt innere sicherheit das hat uns
hier auch dieses ergebnis letztlich im
polarisierenden wahlkampf der hier
geführt worden ist ermöglicht und
insofern kann ich nur festhalten die
partei hat hier fantastisch
zusammengearbeitet wir hatten ein
unheimlich großen zuspruch und eine
unheimlich große unterstützung von auch
als in anderen landesverbänden der
partei hier waren hunderte wahlhelfer
unterwegs die uns unterstützt haben die
auch dazu mit beigetragen haben dass wir
als partei mit relativ geringen mitteln
dem verhältnis zu anderen parteien
ausgestattet sind dass wir hier diesen
wahlkampf so führen konnten wie
ehrgefühl geführt worden ist und dieses
wahlergebnis hat sicherlich eins
vielleicht nicht ganz so abgebildet aber
die stimmung auf den straßen sachsen
anhalts das war auch eine stimmung für
uns das sind ganz viele menschen eine in
den vorständen und so weiter zu uns
gekommen und haben gesagt macht weiter
halt durch ihr seid die die hier in
diesem land noch veränderungen bewirken
können und ich denke das wahlergebnis
hat er auch gezeigt wir haben uns auf
sehr hohem niveau stabilisiert und
insofern können wir mit diesem
wahlergebnis sehr zufrieden sein
vielen dank
wir kommen jetzt zu ihren fragen die
erste frage kommt online von palla geht
an herrn davon hoffmann geht an den
namen habe ich in form von carglass mann
und geht an den kubala welche lehren
ziehen sie als spitzenkandidatin ihrer
partei aus dem wahlergebnis und sachsen
anhalt auch mit blick auf die
bundestagswahl
ja ein ergebnis in einem flächenland wie
sachsen handel über 20 prozent ist für
uns natürlich absolute motivation auch
für die bundestagswahl ich habe es ja in
meinem eingangsstatement erwähnt wir
sind volkspartei in sachsen anhalt haben
das bestätigt wir wollen natürlich auch
im bund volkspartei werden bzw unser
wahlergebnis von 2017 ausbauen das ist
das ziel für die bundestagswahl und der
ging es mit diesem ergebnis doch mit
angehörigen stück rückenwind aber auch
für uns motivation für unsere mitglieder
natürlich und unsere wahlkämpfer in dem
nächste und anstehende bundestagswahl
die nächste frage kommt von herrn
papa sie haben jetzt im eingangs
statement davon gesprochen dass dieses
wahlergebnis respektabel gewesen weil
ein wort das auch jörg nolte gestern
benutzt hat gestern abend haben sie noch
davon gesprochen das war ein
sensationelles ergebnis
alle zweifel spricht von einem
großartigen ergebnis ich würde jetzt mal
gerne was war das eigentlich für ein
ergebnis respektabel oder sensationell
also ein sensationelles ergebnis kann
genauso respektabel sein also da würde
ich jetzt immer die unterscheidbarkeit
von ihrer seite hätte ich da gerne mal
gewusst also ich finde es immer noch ich
hab's auch hier nochmal erwähnt ein sehr
gutes ergebnis
alles was über 20 prozent ist fallen
unter diesen bedingungen ist auch ein
stück weit sensationell wir haben uns
gefestigt auftrat mit dem medialen
gegenwind den wir erlebt haben diese
polarisierung es gab ja im prinzip fast
brust die abstimmung zwischen cdu und
fdp so hat man zumindest sind die
letzten tage gespürt hat dann doch dazu
geführt dass man gerade auf die
popularität von der nase darauf
abgezielt hat die ihm sicherlich genutzt
hat das will ich überhaupt nicht
verhehlen und er hat uns natürlich auch
ein stück weit themen der genommen und
hat auch ein stück weit auf die politik
betrieben wie sie sich erinnern können
hat er ja klar auch die krone maßnahmen
hier im land sachsen-anhalt hatte
richter kann es sicherlich bestätigen
stark kritisiert und hat im bundesrat
ganz andere töne angeschlagen und hat
dort die die meinung der regierung
unterstützen hat auch zugestimmt dem
vierten bevölkerungsschutz gesetz das
hat uns schon ein bisschen verwundert
diese doppelmoral
hinzu kommt natürlich auch die gerade
die politik was die gez erweiterung bzw
erhöhung der gebühren angeht auch dass
ein fdp mann was ihr sicherlich aus
wahltaktischen gründen mit eingebracht
hat ich bin gespannt aber das jetzt in
der nächsten regierung fortsetzt oder ob
das bis lippenbekenntnisse waren also
von daher denke ich können wir mit
diesem ergebnis sehr gut leben und es
ist trotzdem für mich und auch für uns
als partei ein fantastisches ergebnis
ok jetzt ist fantastisch dass die gez
gibt es übrigens seit jahren nicht mehr
aber das lassen wir ich habe eine andere
frage aber beziehungsweise
postenschacher ist dass das das ergebnis
er hat ja doch einen plan stimmenverlust
also wie viel sie gebracht sie haben
prozente verloren sie haben 14 von 15
direktmandaten verloren wie kann man das
jetzt als fantastisch verzeichnet
bezeichnung wenn man wähler verliert was
ist da los bei der partei die eigentlich
doch eine bewegungs partei sich selber
als bewegungs partei sieht die nach und
nach zulegt und immer stärker wird der
trend ist ein anderer was ist da los
also ich würde jetzt schon einen -3%
kind trend ableiten
direktmandaten
direktmandate kann sicherlich noch was
dazu sagen als als analyse da will ich
mich jetzt überhaupt zu sehr in die
auswertung der landespolitik hinein
betreiben ich finde es trotzdem ein
fantastisches ergebnis und nochmal wir
haben uns als volkspartei dort
konsolidiert wir haben ein starkes
wählerpotenzial und wenn sie sich an das
ergebnis vor fünf jahren in sachsen
anhalt erinnern er wurde getönt in fünf
jahren ist die art die in sachsen-anhalt
geschichte das darf man nicht vergessen
also ich denke schon dass wir uns hier
gerade mit dieser doch tollen
oppositionsarbeit auf der kollegen in
sachsen anhalt einen namen gemacht haben
wir haben immer den finger in die wunde
gelegt wir sind das korrektiv was wir
als opposition auch sein wollen und was
man braucht und sie haben sie erlebt
auch wie schwierig ist die die koalition
in sachsen anhalt hatte die regierung
stand mehrfach kurz vor dem bruch und
oder den aktuellen ergebnissen wie man
jetzt sehen wird es eine sehr schwache
ergebnis knapp über ist wahrscheinlich
mit der spd ich denke die afg wird
weiterhin der treiber sein und das ist
auch richtig und gut zu
ergänzen kurz ja also natürlich haben
wir auch wähler verloren aber natürlich
gab es auch in diesem wahlkampf neue
parteien wie die
wie die basis zum beispiel die basis hat
glaube ich einem prozent erreicht die
freien wähler lagen bei 3 prozent die
hatten wir in der letzten landtagswahl
nicht und aber im wahlkampf nicht da
haben wir auch natürlich wähler verloren
aber ich muss ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen
bei dem was uns entgegengebracht wurde
bei diesem wahlkampf bei der
berichterstattung bei allem was da auf
gefahren wurde die kirchen der vsg das
ganze ganze problematik finde ich fast
21 prozent schon gut und ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich gebe gerne kurzfristig
für fünf jahre mal zwei prozent ab wenn
ich dabei erreiche dass die grünen eben
nicht von diesem bergheim mitgehabt
werden sondern die wollen ja vorher bei
den umfragen bei 89 fast zehn prozent
und sind jetzt bei 5,9 gelandet die
waren vorher bei 5,2 also die haben wir
schön daher lassen wo sie sind und wo
sie auch hingehören und die spd haben
wir einstellig gemacht personen nur
erfolg unsererseits und damit kann ich
dann auch wirklich leben weil das
landtag konservative wären endlich haben
diese parteien auch mal deutlich
verloren auch gerade die linke mit über
5 prozent das ist für mich auch
anerkennung unserer arbeit und ich
glaube dass wir da gute arbeit gemacht
haben was er in haseldorf betrifft er
hat natürlich er hat natürlich
positionen vertreten die er nie
eingehalten hat der heute in
sachsen-anhalt weg gehen der sache gab
es nicht mal angefangen diesen weg zu
gehen hat die bundes notbremse als
erster mit unterschrieben hat da vorher
gewettert da wurde bei der volksstimme
ein interview gegeben dass er sich
wünsche dass die korona politik von der
kanzlerin betrieben werde das wurde dann
am abend noch von erfolg stimme gelöscht
das ganze interview damit nicht mehr
öffentlichkeit erscheint wurde von der
süddeutschen länder kansas heute noch
lesen und zehn tage stellt sich derselbe
mann nehmen und sagt also die kora
politik die die kanzlerin macht die
können wir nicht gebrauchen das ist doch
gegen ministerpräsident so was und ich
muss ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen wenn alle
parteien durch das hoch schreiben
unserer partei auf dieselben werte wie
die cdu und ich glaube schon dass die
damals mögliche stimmte habe diese ganze
umfrage werde die wahl hätten zwischen
326 prozent wenn dann selbst linke in
größenordnung mehr als wir
wähler verlieren an die cdu oder die
bewusst die cdu wählen um uns zu
verhindern dann ist dieses ergebnis also
aus meiner sicht wirklich ein gutes
ergebnis muss ich ihnen zu sagen ich hab
ja man muss auch zu den direktmandat
muss man folgendes sagen ich hatte das
auch vorher schon den innerparteilichen
diskussionen immer eingebracht wir
müssen da mit taktischen wlan rechnen
die hat es gegeben gerade eben durch den
hier genannten durch die polarisierung
die es vorher gegeben hat und die
entsprechenden stimmen bewegungen gerade
von den linken und auch von der spd
zur cdu sind hier ein deutliches zeichen
und es ist ja so für ein direktmandat
auch in sachsen anhalt auch bei der
letzten wahl da sind eben die letzten 23
prozent entscheidend und dadurch ist der
rückgang der direktmandate zu erklären
umgekehrt haben wir aber bei weitem
nicht diese menge an mandaten im
parlament verloren da können wir
weiterhin sehr zufrieden sein die
fraktion ist stark ähnlich wie vorher
insofern ist das einfach sage ich mal
diesem phänomen geschuldet ich denke
davon muss man sich hier gar nicht bange
machen lassen wenn eine frage online von
einem guten modus
was sagen sie den 22 prozent ihrer
wähler in sachsen-anhalt wir finden dass
sich ihre partei nicht genug von
rechtsextremistischen positionen
distanziert
würde ich erst mal fragen wir dazu kommt
und
distanzieren uns von allen
rechtsextremistischen tendenzen die es
geben sollte wir sind klar gegen
extremismus ich kann hier nur unseren
ehrenvorsitzenden hermann zitieren und
das ist für mich auch die rote linie in
unserer partei wer ein problem mit dem
grundgesetz hat in unserer partei der
gehört nicht zu unserer partei also von
daher ist damit alles gesagt hey yo
dann weil ihr landesverband sachsen
anhalter schon palla ist ja offen
rechtsextrem neben ihnen sitzen
rechtsextremisten warum das dann ziehen
sie sich dann nicht von herrn kirchner
der die krone pandemie als schwere
grippewelle verharmlost bereich hat
gerade von der förderung von familien
geredet da geht es aber auch laut ihrem
wahlprogramm und im parteiprogramm um
deutsche eltern die haben begrüßungsgeld
bekommen sollen wenn neugeborene kommen
nicht ausländische eltern und ist dieser
offen rechtsextremistische kurs ihres
landesverband vorbild für die
bundestagswahl ich kann ihnen gerne
weiter gehen weil ich distanziere mich
nur von aussagen die ich selbst tätige
und für die ich selbst verantwortung
trage und gericht als landesvorsitzende
die haben die ihnen gerade als
rechtsextremisten ihr bezeichnet ich
denke er kann ihnen gerne auskunft geben
das gar nicht gerne tun nicht meine
wenden linksextremer journalist mich
rechtsextremer nennt dann muss ich ihnen
ganz ehrlich sagen das wäre ja so als
wenn wir ihre kinder ddr die demokratie
erklären wollen jetzt müssen sie mir mal
erklären wo ich rechtsextrem bin wenn
mir der mir die der verfassungsschutz
vorwürfe rechtsextrem zu sein weil ich
in einer landtagsdebatte zum
ministerpräsidenten der
ministerpräsident ich lasse nicht
kampflos zu dass sie die zukunft meiner
kinder bleiben das bestimme ich schon
gerne selbst wenn das für sie als
journalist ausreicht dass jemand
rechtsextremist dann nehme ich das zur
kenntnis kann da aber wirklich nur laden
und schmunzeln darüber
dann eine frage von frage war ja ob sie
diesen offenen rechtsextremistischen
kurs ist das alles nachzulesen warum
herr kirchner als rechtsextrem gilt ja
den link auf den seen sie so als links
journalist diesen kurs gibt es nie und
sie wissen ganz genau dass das
behauptungen einer behörde sind mit der
wm rechtsstreit sind und diese
rechtsstreit warten wir gemeinsam erst
mal ab vielen dank herr reichert
muss auch mal ganz deutlich sagen sie
arbeiten doch hier mit völlig aus dem
zusammenhang gerissen und auch falschen
aussagen also erstens mal steht
überhaupt nichts davon drinne dass das
nur deutsche kinder sein müssen und
ähnlich ist das steht nicht im programm
das ist einfach falsch es steht dort
musiziert und ganz genau es steht dort
ein deutsches elternteil drin das ist
richtig dazu stehen doch glatt das hatte
aber nichts mit nur deutschen eltern zu
tun entschuldung das ist einfach unwahr
sie haben hier schon mit einer unwahren
frage das ganze eröffnet es geht hier
gar nicht um nur deutsche eltern wenn da
ein elternteil leben nicht aus
deutschland stammt dann ist hat auch das
kind einen migrationshintergrund oder
ähnliches ist also völlig falsch es ist
genau die art von journalismus die uns
überall entgegen schlägt mit
halbwahrheiten arbeiten sie und dann
bringen sie die frage auf sie sagen
jemand ist rechtsextrem ist weil er die
korona maßnahmen anzweifelt da stelle
ich mir schon die frage wo da überhaupt
der zusammenhang besteht das ist also
eine eine fragestellung die ist also ist
aber die ist ja schon intellektuell für
jemanden der das noch halbwegs klar
durchblickt überhaupt nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar sie sind offensichtlich
ein ideologischer journalist und
versuchen hier unsere partei in eine
extremistische ecke zu schieben und das
ist genau das was leider viel zu oft
passiert ich will ihnen mal ganz ehrlich
sagen das muss man endlich auch darüber
gesprochen werden bei uns wird alles
mögliche in die rechtsextreme ecke
gestellt was fragen sie denn eigentlich
bei den grünen nach den k gruppen die
dort ministerpräsident geworden sind was
fragen sie denn bei herrn trittin nach
seiner politischen grund gesinnung da
sind maoisten dabei in führenden
positionen die sind damals einem mann
hinterher gelaufen der für den tod von
millionen menschen verantwortlich ist
hier wäre doch mal der kritischen
journalismus in deutschland gefragt der
findet aber nicht statt stattdessen
präsentiert man einen bär burgheim und
tut so als wären die grünen eine
bürgerliche partei jetzt lassen sie mich
kurz ein wort sagen ich glaube das wird
kein deut weiter kommen wenn wir uns
jetzt hier gegenseitig beschimpfen sie
hier oben nicht die kolleginnen und
kollegen im saal bettler nicht und für
die kolleginnen und kollegen im saal
bitte ich es eben schaffen sich zu tun
unsere gäste zu beschimpfen so machen
wir weiter
warf an der fernsehen herr kirchner die
sprachen davon dass sie fünf jahren eine
potenzielle regierungsbeteiligung
anstreben wie soll denn das
funktionieren das ist das nicht
wunschdenken wo gerade ein
ministerpräsident haseloff gerade
stimmen dazu gewonnen hat weil er sich
zu stark von der fdp abgrenzt apropos
wie wichtig ist ihnen denn überhaupt
eine regierungsbeteiligung ist die
oppositionsarbeit nicht die bequemere
eigentlich für die
harfenistin falsch was sie behaupten der
ist nicht durch sich mit zu diesem
wahlergebnis erlangt hat das sonder
erlangt bei aller anderen den kampf
gegen rechts geführt haben gegen uns und
zwar die linken die spd die grünen und
die fdp die am wählerschichten in
riesengroßen maßen dorthin abgesandt um
uns zu verhindern das hat mit deren
haseldorf relativ wenig zu tun und jetzt
warten wir mal fünf jahre hat was der
kollege haseldorf führen sachsen anhalt
weg vorschlägt und wir denn die 1,5
milliarden die wir bei der gez aber
keinen rechtlichen rahmen geschaffen
haben dafür eine abstimmung zu machen
und damit rechtlich dafür zu sorgen dass
diese 1,5 milliarden gefordert werden
sind im öffentlich rechtlichen nicht von
sachsen anhalt jetzt hier vor ort wären
wir sind pleite wir haben kein geld mehr
die steuer schwankungsreserve ist alle
das sind alles gut aus sachsen anhalt zu
kommen und da bin ich mal sehr gespannt
wie er mit dieser truppe die er da jetzt
vielleicht zusammen wählt diese probleme
lösen will dann gucken wir mal in fünf
jahren die cdu in fünf jahren steht und
wo wir in fünf jahren stehen jetzt in
die glaskugel zu gucken vorher ich habe
das so gesagt und das ist mein ziel dass
ich habe und da können wir vielleicht in
vier jahren noch mal darüber sprechen
glaube ich
ja vielleicht auch mal anschließend an
ihre frage wir sind vor fünf jahren als
starke position den landtag erstmalig
eingezogen wir haben heute wie gesagt
oder gestern regierung gesehen auch was
das ergebnis angeht das ist ja ganz
normal bevor man in
regierungsverantwortung kommen dass man
natürlich erstmal oppositionsarbeit noch
leistet und sich auch dort beweisen muss
und es wird die zukünftige fraktion im
sack zu sechs in sachsen anhaltinischen
landtag leisten wenn ich voll überzeugt
man hat wahrscheinlich die möglichkeit
weiterhin auch untersuchungsausschüsse
einzurichten die mehrheitsverhältnisse
jetzt aktuell sind das hoffe ich
zumindest
damit kann man diesen druck ausüben und
dann wird man durch eigeninitiativen
aber auch durch gute parlamentarische
arbeit sich auch anbieten und dann wird
es denke ich mal wenn die
mehrheitsverhältnisse vielleicht wieder
andere sind auch bei der cdu in gewisser
weise ein umdenken geben das ist ein
prozess diese geduld brauchen wir
politik ist ein langlauf kein kein
kurzer sprint und von daher bin ich da
relativ optimistisch
die versuche eine zusammenarbeit oder
eine annäherung mit der cdu anzustreben
wenn ich das richtig verstehe ich
versuche jetzt fundamental opposition zu
machen und vernünftige sache anträge in
den inn in das parlament einzubringen um
den bürger genau das weiter fortzusetzen
was wir vorher gemacht haben und wenn
sich dann die prognose so wie ich sie im
kopf habe dahingehend entwickelt das die
cdu nämlich wieder schwächer wird mit
dem dass ich jetzt wieder mit zwei
verlierern das fünf jahre überbrücken in
diesem bau in unserem bundesland da bin
ich fest überzeugt davon bei den
problemen die uns jetzt erwarten mit
insolvenzen mit leuten in die armut
treiben mit kein geld mehr in der kasse
und neuen schulden machen die andere
bezahlen müssen da kommen so viele
sachen jetzt auf diesen
ministerpräsident mit diesen beiden die
er sich jetzt zusammen wählt dazu dass
wir das ganz entspannt von hinten uns
angucken und oppositionsarbeit leisten
um genau das nämlich aufzudecken was da
alles so im vorfeld passiert ist und wo
wir jetzt die vor irgendwann zu erwarten
haben
ich weiß nicht ein wenig die frage
richten soll stellen sie allgemein ihr
ergebnis hat aber natürlich zum inhalt
dass ihnen wählerstimmen abhanden
gekommen sind die sie 2016 noch hatten
es gab zwei große wählerwanderung ströme
30.000 stimmen sind ins lager der
nichtwähler gegangen
22.000 zur cdu und die cdu ist keine
neue partei die nicht wähler eigentlich
auch nicht was haben sie da falsch
gemacht welche hoffnungen haben sie
nicht erfüllen bei menschen die sie
2016 noch gewählt hatten ich kann
natürlich kurz vor beginn ehrlich wir
werden auch eine nachwahl betrachtung
machen und es wird auch gern auch die
umfragen bei uns sagen was die konkreten
gründe sind das wissen wir ja alle noch
nicht fakt ist und wenn man jetzt sich
die alterskohorten ansieht dass man dass
wir sehr wohl zumindestens die älteren
rentner dass die ehe er doch die cdu
gewählt haben das kann durchaus mit der
krone politik in zusammenhang genommen
werden das ist durchaus möglich
inwieweit wird auch nicht mobilisieren
können aber herr kirchner als eingangs
erwähnt was auch die die
splitterparteien unter sonstiges angeht
sollte man sich auch betrachten das sind
fast 10 prozent so einen hohen wert habe
ich eigentlich selten bei einer wahl
gesehen die sich dort oft geteilt haben
also das hat uns mit sicherheit auch die
stimmen gekostet nichtsdestotrotz
natürlich die die stimmen die an die cdu
gegangen sind sind sicherlich ein stück
weit der agile rentner und wir werden
uns auch anschauen was die themen waren
die wir mit denen wir vielleicht nicht
gezogen haben und das haben wir
natürlich auch auswerten und auch für
die bundestagswahl ist das natürlich für
uns sehr wichtig das zu analysieren doch
abzustellen ganz klar
ja nach den vorliegenden zahlen haben
wir also im verhältnis zu 216 6000
nichtwähler gewonnen und haben 11.000
wähler an die union verloren das ist
natürlich nicht schön dass wir die
verloren habe aber man muss eben auch
auf diesen polarisierenden wahlkampf
schauen und da muss man eben auch sagen
dass die linke 13.000 wähler und die spd
15.000 wähler an die union verloren hat
und das ist dann eben auch teil der
wahrheit
gut dann haben wir unterschiedliche
zahlen über wählerwanderungen die die
ich kenne sind diejenigen die ihre
partei verloren hat aber lassen wir das
dahin gestellt sein
die zweite frage die ich habe oder die
vertiefung frage die ich habe
was bedeutet es wenn das ziel das sie
selbst ja auch noch vertreten hatten
wenige wochen vor der wahl nämlich
stärkste partei werden zu wollen stärker
jedenfalls als die cdu das haben sie
krachend verfehlt das muss man so offen
sagen dann sind sie zwar vielleicht
volkspartei aber keine erfolgs partei an
dem kriterium gemessen woran hat das
gelegen was haben sie da falsch gemacht
also erfolgs partei sind wir weiterhin
man muss natürlich auch mal die frage an
die demoskopen was hier für wahlumfragen
teilweise die letzten wochen gekommen
sind die haben den schluss zugelassen
auch für uns wahlkämpfer dass es ein
kopf an kopf rennen ist das muss man
ganz klar analysieren und natürlich
geben wir dann bei solchen wahlumfragen
auch das ziel heraus dass wir gewinnen
wollen also werden wir denn wenn der in
eine landtagswahl wo im prinzip zwei
konkurrierende parteien sich um die
macht streiten beziehungsweise um den
erfolg streiten dass wir dann sagen wir
wollen zweiter wären also natürlich ist
für uns das ziel und die marschroute
gewesen natürlich diese landtagswahl zu
gewinnen aber ich habe schon gesagt
politik ist marathon das nächste mal
gewinde sie
noch kurz zur gänze wollen also ich habe
nie davon gesprochen 30 prozent zu
erreichen die zahl wurde heim auf dem
bundesparteitag ressort von einem
bundesvorsitzende unserer partei ich
wollte damals noch ins mikrofon geben
das relativieren wäre war die schlange
an dem mikrofon so lang dass es dann
nicht mehr dazu gekommen ist aber ich
habe diese zeilen nähe sagt ich habe
immer gesagt wenn wir zwischen 23 und 26
prozent kommen dann ist das in ordnung
und das wäre auch so gekommen wenn nicht
alle anderen diese partei mit ihr wählt
hätten und das ist eben stück der
wahrheit ich habe das nur behauptet mit
31 prozent aber das gewinnen zu wollen
ich würde mich darüber freuen das habe
ich immer gesagt das hätte ich mich auch
aber das habe ich nie behauptet
erfolg ja
die frage ist die erwähnten vorhin im
griff stammwählerschaft die sie haben
und auf der anderen seite gab es ja
gerade aus den neuen bundesländern viele
stimmen nach den wahlen in rheinland
pfalz und baden württemberg die dahin
gingen dass die afg hauptsächlich sich
auf die nichtwähler konzentrieren sollte
oder die als wählerschicht in besonders
ansprechen sollte nun sind die ihr zu
großen teilen zur cdu gegangen diesmal
ist es so dass jetzt die afg vielleicht
doch einsehen muss die hat ein
wählerpotenzial das liegt im osten um
die 20 und im westen um die neun prozent
das ist eine kernklientel die ist auch
unabhängig von dem wie partei so nach
außen performt oder was der
verfassungsschutz sagt dass das also
quasi ihre zielgruppe ist um die sie
sich vorher nicht kümmern müssen
ja ich denke 21 prozent haben wir die
zielgruppe weit gefächert auch in der
bevölkerung und das lokale unterschiede
gibt auch zwischen verschiedenen
parteien das sieht man ja am besten an
der spd die sich im prinzip im osten
komplett fast auslöst also es sind ja
auch alles parteien der sogenannten
mitte wenn ich liebe diese abgeschnitten
haben denke ich haben wir doch in der
breiten mehrheit von der mitte bis
natürlich rechts haben wir 21 prozent
ein sehr respektables ergebnis und haben
bei breite wählerschichten abgefangen
inwieweit natürlich mehr nichtwähler
mobilisiert werden können wie gesagt da
denke ich mal auch auf die
wahlbeteiligung angeht ja nicht groß
gestiegen ist hat sicherlich auch die
die korona maßnahmen dazu beigetragen
und dass man die wähler nicht zu
mobilisieren konnte das
sehr wohl zur kenntnis in welcher weise
das natürlich ist ein ausschuss hatte
wenn man nochmal sehen in der nacht nach
weite kracht und wie schon erwähnt habe
ja es ging eher sind die richtung dass
es doch eine gewisse vergleichbarkeit
gibt zwischen west und ost zwar auf
unterschiedlichem niveau aber die
verluste bei den landtagswahlen war
jetzt nicht besonders unterschiedlich
während ja auch gestern kamen ja wieder
die aussage die afg müsse im westen mehr
osten machen aber ich sag mal minus 3,4
prozent würden die noch nichts nützen
vollrath da muss ich ein bisschen
widersprechen wenn ich in rheinland
pfalz bei 13 prozent und 5 prozent
verliere und sachsen anhalt bei 23
prozent 24 prozent und drei verlierer
ist es schon im prozentuale unterschied
vereinigen von der verhältnismäßigkeit
das natürlich gerade die sozialen themen
und ich habe das in seinem
eingangsstatement ja gesagt gezogen
haben das ist wichtige themen sind das
zum beispiel auch das haben ja die
bereits auswertungen die ersten gezeigt
dass die klimapolitik zum beispiel bei
den sachsen anhalt hier überhaupt keine
rolle gespielt hat in der
wahlentscheidung zeigt ja eigentlich die
unterscheidbarkeit und wir werden grad
nach kronor mit vielen sozialen fragen
was wirtschaftspolitik angeht was mit
der grat beginnenden installationen die
allen vielen bereichen und was die
rohstoffe angeht beginnend ist für den
mittelstand für das handwerk während der
themen haben auf die wir gut vorbereitet
sind und das wird auch für uns ein
wichtiges thema im bundestagswahlkampf
sein und genau auf diese themen zu
konzentrieren was die energiewende die
verfehlte energiepolitik der
bundesregierung angeht also mehr ich bin
überhaupt nicht mehr überhaupt nicht
bange was die themen angeht also die
liegen fast auf der straße und
nachgeholt werden wir mehr themen haben
als vielleicht sogar vorher weil durch
die korona maßnahmen hat sich eigentlich
alles wie unter einem brennglas
gezeigt hat noch verstärkt die probleme
haben sich verstärkt und von daher denke
ich mal wie gesagt bin ich sehr
optimistisch dass wir dort mit reichlich
themen und auch mit antworten in die
bundestagswahl gehen können er passt
eine frage an herrn pofalla oder gerne
auch an die beiden anderen an herrn
kirschner und herren reichert
compiler sie haben die vorwürfe schon so
ein bisschen zurückgewiesen die fdp und
sachsen anhalt steht zu weit rechts
jetzt haben aber dieser vorwurf ja nicht
von außen sondern auch direkt von ihrer
parteispitze
erneuten hat gesagt dass er glaube die
partei sei zu weit rechts wahrgenommen
worden in sachsen anhalt und er würde
sich weniger protest kurs und mehr mitte
wünschen hat der parteichef morton recht
ja ich habe es ja gerade in der letzten
frage eigentlich beantwortet wenn man 21
hat dann ist man volkspartei hat man aus
allen wählerschichten auch natürlich die
prozente bekommen sie wollen wir jetzt
nicht sagen dass 21 prozent der sachsen
anhalt kinder nur die auf die gewählte
und weise rechts sind nein wir sind die
kümmerer partei wir haben uns um die
bedürfnisse und vor allen dingen die die
wünsche der wähler gekümmert die nehmen
wir als auftrag und das ist weiterhin
unser ansatz dass wir das natürlich in
ins parlament tragen dass wir vor allen
dingen den unmut die auf der straße
herrscht und der ist ja überall sichtbar
nicht nur durch corona dass wir das
natürlich ins parlament tragen denn da
gehört sind dort müssen die
parlamentarischen entscheidungen
getroffen werden das ist unser ansatz
und da sehe ich uns auch weiterhin gut
aufgestellt über die strömung in unserer
partei die es ja gibt und die auch
wichtig und nutzt voll sind weil wir als
volkspartei natürlich verschiedene
strömungen haben das hat jede partei hat
die spd ist hat die cdu und von daher
sehe ich an unserem kurs er besteigt als
ich geschwächt sehe